hold on hold on and then you add the
picture of the cop that's kneeling on
his neck good make America white again
wearing that hat
why would he wearing that way that way I
mean did you not see this the picture of
him
it's the same cop wearing maybe miracle
why were you in that hat
yes no way I don't know if it's true or
not but I've seen it floating around
faked I've seen it floating around that
would be like but people are I mean
people are I mean it if I've seen it
they've seen it let's pull it find it
yeah sure actually can you start digging
that up so I think it's gonna require a
little bit we got to be real careful on
that stuff okay because well for the
record I've seen this picture of
floating around a lot today is it like
if they're spreading it around there
they got a picture of him on his on his
neck and the picture next to each other
and they're like boom so in a different
picture this guy was wearing different
picture yeah oh man yeah we definitely
got to find that yeah absolutely
I mean it's but think about that you
know it's like man that's if this is the
case it's not only okay so people are
saying it's a fake picture okay all
right so it being fake that's still
being spread around yeah it's it's you
know more tinder on the flame of what's
going on today let me give a shout out
to the chat yeah best fact-checkers in
my Oh seriously I love art I love it I
love our chat yo shout out to all our
our people here with us because you guys
are awesome I really appreciate you we
got 50 million chats coming in and like
every second and it's all fake fake fake
that good that's cool you know but but
I'm like here's the thing I can't read
any individual one but seeing fake a
thousand times yeah that's fine that's
fine
I I wasn't saying that that's that is
like hey it is out there and people
believe it because that what is what
happened they see they don't even read
an article they see the title and post
it along and be like see I'm justified
let's go loot more there's know what's
really making me angry yeah that I was I
was talking to a friend of mine who is
lefty you know does it follow any
conservative news any conservative
personalities and I brought up that
these they're showing these memes of
libertarian and conservative two-way
activists standing on the steps of
Michigan or you know reopen activists
yeah and they're saying things like look
what happens when these white people
with guns known does anything to them
and the joking thing the first and
foremost is like makes a good point
about the Second Amendment right like
the cops don't want to get there someone
made a really great point about this
they tweeted at me and they said it's
not there someone tweeted something like
if you give all these riders weapons
mm-hmm and the police start firing
teargas what do you think would happen
and they responded with no because the
police would be very very careful firing
if they were dealing with armed
activists marching fully armed after
they wouldn't just are firing at people
they would back off and they calm down
because they're trying to desperately
avoid a confrontation to deescalate
here's one here's what really bugged me
out talking to my friend and it's no
dick in my friend my friend just you
know where I was I was like it's sad to
me that these these like two-way
activists standing on these steps agree
about this guy getting his life taken
away from him you know and I'm like this
could have been an amazing moment to say
you know we may disagree on a lot having
to do with this yeah we can all agree
there needs to be justice and then there
could have been this unity but it really
really messes with me when you see the
left doesn't care about what
conservatives think they don't care who
these people are you know and why I'm
like what why are you ragging on these
these guys into anything to you
this is an opportunity for you to like
reach out your head and say we need your
help like this guy's rights were
violated you know and they would have
been like yeah it's sad man people are
so are so driven by tribalism you know
who did it it's Lenny about some of my
friend I was like what's really
fascinating right now it's happening
across the country is that these these
urban cops have lost the goodwill of so
many of the right so so many individuals
on the right for a vote for violating
the Constitution with these decrees I'm
talking about small-town cops I'm
talking about NYPD and LAPD mm-hm when
they were given an executive decree by
the governor and then all these
conservatives were like you can't do
this and they were like watch me and
they're like wow oh and and I'm seeing
people calm both breakers and I'm like
yes technically correct that is correct
yeah cuz we saw the good cops like that
guy in Seattle yeah I'm not gonna
enforce these unconstitutional laws you
can't make us fire to go
tired for it it's like that's a boss
right that do ya upholding the
Constitution you know what I really
there was a there was a I think what was
I think it was the mother of all rallies
who's called we're a bunch of Trump
supporters doing a big thing in DC black
lives matter should have to protest it
and then the Trump supporters invited
vitamin stage I like that yeah yeah it
was I think it was Hank Newsom who's a
black lives matter
lefty cultural guy okay a lot of things
I disagree with him on but he's a cool
dude he's really as I think he's a cool
dude so he shows up there that a protest
but the Trump supporters were like why
don't you come on stage and tell us like
we're gonna we want we want to respect
you and you want to hear your side of
things and you know what ended up
happening at first every was a lot a
preventive and then the I think it was
hanky said we're not anti cop we're anti
bad cop but we want our constitutional
rights and then the crowd goes the crowd
yeah exactly and you know II wasn't
expecting that no they thought they were
enemies right and then when he came down
apparently like like there's photos like
everyone's like trying to get pictures
with him and they're like you're really
great like this is exactly what we've
been saying yeah
not realizing and that you know makes me
angry you see these Sarah Silverman you
see UCS celebrities they're the ones
driving a wedge between us because we
may disagree on like racial issues and
social justice but we agree on our
fundamental rights and there's and
there's a line where we might be alike I
won't stand next to you because I think
you're going nuts but four fundamental
issues like this we can solve this
problem I think it's to be a bit more on
the conspirator against peer toriel side
it's a they don't want us to yeah you
know I mean mmm-hmm I think I mention
this the other day that comic about
Occupy Wall Street yeah it's a it's a
it's a fat cat rich guy in his room and
then there's a bunch people outside with
Occupy signs and then he's on the phone
laughing saying introduce them to
identity politics and that's it and then
all of a sudden they're fighting each
other and that and that and that's
they're trying to maintain that the
class system that they have anyways make
the poor people fight each other and
they don't gotta fight us that's what
that's what the crazy thing about occupy
income yeah occupy was everybody versus
the 1% yeah and then all of a sudden the
millionaire you know black woman is now
oppressed and the homeless white man is
the oppressor so
would you say that that was the start of
this identity politics occupy occupy um
occupy was one of the first social
justice like moments in culture okay but
it had started a couple years earlier in
media and then it manifested physically
as far as I can tell for the first time
with Occupy Wall Street it was very
because even during occupy it wasn't
absolute right like the social justice
sjw dogma stuff it wasn't absolute there
was people arguing over it hmm if there
was an Occupy protest today it would
100% be social justice dogma
intersectionality yes I was called
interest you know that's the proper name
you know back then a lot of people
disagree with it and there was only a
small handful of people enforcing it
because half the half of the the park
didn't agree with it and half did this
is a crazy story man with Occupy there
was a group of people living in the park
who separated and formed their own
governing body they called it the
general union okay
the general assembly was the power
structure it was college educated upper
class and trust fund kids they would
they lived in Brooklyn they would either
train into the park hold meetings
dictating what to do with with all the
money they raised the people who lived
in the park the poor people decided
because they couldn't get fair
representation at the General Assembly
that they would create their own system
called the general union where your
voting power was based on your tent so
you get all these tents and they said
every everybody sends a rep from their
tent so if there's two or three people
in the tent one person goes and we make
decisions they were going to have their
own meeting on the other side of the
park it was the west side of the park
and facilitators they called them showed
up and shut the event down and wouldn't
let them organize
it was the creepiest thing I'd ever seen
mmm yep and one of the dudes who
organized started crying so like I got
threatened by two guys they they said
they told me to shut up or they'd shut
me up cuz I was just filming know
something I'm like these guys have
something to say and they were like the
General Assembly activists showed up to
their side and started going Mic Check
Mic Check Mic Check over and over again
and the crowd just mindlessly drones
along so that no meeting could take
place that was creepy that was really
creepy and then the only thing you could
do
they started was was go to the General
Assembly they started putting up flyers
saying anybody collecting donations for
occupy was was scamming you hmm
so the only way to give them money was
through their official channel where
they made a bunch of money
one guy was spending nights at luxury
hotels people were stealing stuff oh man
yep yep and I'm like corruption absolute
corruption absolute corruption and there
was one moment the way that because the
General Assembly didn't work it was like
the General Assembly was everyone sits
down and then they say I want to do this
and then everyone raises their hands if
someone blocked it but making an X it
was stopped until you could get past
that block one block it was done unless
they moved for like a supermajority
and there was one moment where they were
trying to do something with money and
there were a bunch of people blocking it
and so then they said we can't move
forward because we have all these blocks
we're gonna vote for a supermajority and
the guy just everyone raises their hands
and but people make the block sign and
then he goes yep yep we got it we're
good and then they're like wait what no
it goes no we're good we're good
everybody and then they were like no no
no no wait what he didn't even count
yeah now he lied he just rushed it
through one woman claimed that she what
like she said I guess privately that she
it got it got too complicated dealing
with what people wanted to vote on so
she was just by whatever she wanted with
the money Wow yeah she's honest yeah so
so anyway I know I'm going off on a
tangent on Occupy stuff
that's right but there were early on I I
guess a lot people don't know this there
were older people there there were
libertarians there there people waving
the American flag there were
conservatives and two things conspired
to end bet the first is that young
people have more ability to just sleep
in a park there was like a 60 year old
man and woman they can't sleep in a park
so these dog days are over right they
they showed up they were there for one
weekend came back the next weekend and
then went home the people who had jobs
said that was a fun weekend and went
home but the people who were there was a
couple trust fund kids they're like they
just had trust funds they didn't have to
do anything mm-hmm
so they were there all the time
controlling and dictating and completely
clueless how to make things these things
run so you ended up with conservatives
who have jobs libertarians who have jobs
and older people who tend to be
conservative needing to leave leaving
nothing but young idealists who didn't
work
interesting never selection and then
several weeks later it was a bunch of
the young people who didn't do anything
there was a lot of corruption man there
was one one something happened where
rumor started spreading that Radiohead
was gonna play a performance totally
fake and then when thousands of people
showed up they were like radio it's not
playing but now we're gonna do a general
assembling you're gonna stay and
everyone was scared because they didn't
want to create the appearance that they
only showed up for Radiohead so it
tricked thousands of people staying in
the park for that for that duration yeah
dude that stuff was so corrupt and
what's funny is you know it's you know
it's really really scary about my
experience at Occupy Wall Street but I'm
not gonna write a book about it the
people who do write books about it are
the ones who are romanticizing it you
gotta write a book about it Tim nope why
not because I don't care
no and that's that's the point um maybe
if I write a book at some point I will
write about it yeah but you know it'll
happen 12 24 36 activists will say
temples line that never happened and
they'll say oh well it's disputed see
all of these people who are there agree
yeah all the people who want it to be
glorified right who ignore the
corruption who ignore how money was or
my heart of it yeah yeah exactly
the people who be accused would be so so
what'll happen is they'll do a
fact-checking the bike well they say it
never happened you say it did and this
other guy said you're lying so now we
have three people saying you're lying
that's why I'm not gonna get involved
there have already been books written
about it that glorify everyone was there
I was there with you I can I can vouch
for you okay when I first met you you
did hmm
really I remember you briefly you
mentioned to me before but I only
remember meeting you at the game shop in
2014 that's what yeah that's true well I
was I was there at a Wall Street and I
saw you and Luke oh right on
and I I think I said I no I don't think
I said anything I'm maybe we didn't meet
at that time like oh that's pretty mad
yeah it was at the game same job yeah
and then you were like come hang out
would play poker night but it's magic
yeah yeah cool
yeah I went down there a few times
though yep Wow at first it was kind of
cool something happening it had this
period where it became Colonial
Williamsburg where like people were
tourists were walking in
one of the funniest things when they
gave dumpster food to tourists I loved
it I walked up and I watched them
handing out food to tourists like tours
would come by and they would have food
light out and they'd be like oh what's
this like it's free you could have it
little did I know there was vegan pizza
no I wasn't being at time but no it was
funny because I watched I watched them
giving out food and then I asked him
where they got the food from and they
were like dumpster diving yeah and I
said are you crazy do you have any idea
what the press would say they found out
you were giving dumpster food to people
and they immediately panicking like
shuffled it to the trash and we're like
who are they thinking they're they're
idealistic hippies who think that like
dumpster food is fine like they weren't
giving you like rotten burgers that were
half-eaten it's like it was like sealed
yogurts that were like a day from
expiration and the point I'm making is
not that like they've got moldy food
ingredients dump exactly they were
freegans they were finding stores that
were getting rid of through those about
to spoil or a couple days past
expiration you know and they're like
it's still food and it's still good you
don't scary about that though these
freegans don't realize that you might
not see the mold or the botulism on it I
think it's gross that's why you get rid
of it those girls they they say that
like you know when you see the mold on
the bread
that means the bread was already mouldy
like mold is on it before you can't see
yeah they were giving that stuff out huh
yeah dude so it's it's very much so in
the vein of histories written by the
winners you've got all of these
activists who want it to be this
glorious revolution of occupied when in
reality it was a mash up mangled like
conspiracy ridden corrupt really just
awful thing but I will tell you one
funny thing about it the evolution of
music at Occupy Wall Street was
absolutely hilarious when Occupy first
started people were just banging on
buckets doom doom doom doom doom doom
doom then all of a sudden they
introduced some like wind instruments
and someone showed up like dude then
someone brought string and I'm like by
the end of it there was a full band with
real drums and yeah and I was like it
was almost like the evolution of
humanity
yeah the Stone Age exactly that's us
like they slowly started incorporating
more and more instruments that to me was
really really funny thanks for checking
out this clip from the Tim cast IRL
podcast we do the show live Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m.
if you want to catch the full show tune
into this channel subscribe hit the like
button or check us out on iTunes and
Spotify and we will soon have this
podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you